the nonprofit founded by actor and
activist Sean Penn has joined has joined
sorry bear with me one second has joined
the fight against the corona virus for
about a decade the two-time Oscar winner
and his relief group Corps have been
assisting communities hit by natural
disasters in places like Haiti now
they're helping manage free
drive-through test sites for the virus
in California first on CBS this morning
Corps is announcing new sites in New
Orleans Atlanta and Detroit Jamie yuccas
talked to Penn about his mission to save
lives this is right now an active
shooter scenario the viruses and its
principal focuses on people of color the
elderly the indigenous but it doesn't
really care who else is in the way actor
Sean Penn and his core team of employees
and volunteers have suited up and
stepped into the line of fire at ten
sites around the state including here in
Los Angeles they're distributing free
test kits to free up the city's first
responders for emergency services are
occupying positions that used to be LA
firefighters on this site and the LA
firefighters have skill sets very
specific and we all need them out there
on the street we need the paramedic
corps god forbid there's a brushfire
Penn didn't just mobilize his team he
often works alongside them and each
night Penn gets on a zoom call with site
team leaders to ensure the response is
efficient and effective these are people
new in my life who took an idea we had
and now lead it I spent most of the time
just thinking well this is the next
generation we might be okay
originally it was just California but
now you will be rolling out more sites
yeah our biggest ambition is to be the
or one of the models that's replicable
this is not like building a business
where you have ambitions of being number
one the idea is to as quickly as
possible be a allowed visible example
of what others can do core is expanding
bringing test sites to areas penn
believes have been underserved such as
New Orleans in Detroit Penn sees this as
a vital piece of the puzzle to reopening
states for business I do get people are
struggling in ways that I can't even
imagine and I think we need a really
accurate picture of how much testing is
happening Ashley the oscar-winning actor
rewrote his legacy to include
humanitarian when a massive earthquake
leveled the country of Haiti in 2010
Penn left Hollywood to help in the
recovery efforts and created his
nonprofit when devastating hurricanes
hit in Puerto Rico North Carolina and
Florida his emergency response
organization was on the scene but this
is the group's first pandemic do you
worry about your health I'm pretty
careful god forbid that I make a mistake
it's sick I'm 60 years old that wouldn't
be a good idea and I don't want to be a
drain on the medical system I worry more
about the activity and testing to make
sure he's healthy while working Penn has
had repeated tests for Kovan 19 all
negative there is a will to take risks
but in this case the risk of being sick
is risking other people you become the
gun that's why he now steps in as team
leader another role for an actor who
doesn't like titles people they said use
the word of humanitarian I have great
people my staff that are humanitarians
but I really love feeling like the
plumber who's going to figure it out I
think the same well what do you see is
your role the plumber plumber for CBS
this morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles
like that Sean Penn the plumber not
playing apart this is real life you know
he's right about the need to push
testing into underserved areas every
time we talk about parking lots and
drive up testing I keep thinking to
myself and a lot of people don't have a
car I mean if you don't have one that
puts you at square zero right there from
the get-go don't you think I think so
Tony listen and as great as Sean Penn is
on the big screen as hard as even bigger
than that he doesn't have to do this
this is certainly not a photo op and
I've seen him in Haiti as Jamie pointed
out I've seen him in Katrina I've seen
him in Puerto Rico he deeply deeply
cares so cheering him on always and all
that he does on and off the screen